[Musique]
il ya régulièrement des sondages qui
sont faits qui montrent qu'en grosso
modo les trois quarts des français
considèrent que leur pouvoir d'achat
diminue donc là je crois qu'il ya une
prise de conscience donc il faut avoir
aussi bien à l'insee que les autorités
politiques et c'est moi je rapprocherais
sera du même phénomène de l'insécurité
il ya une dizaine d'années on parler de
sentiment d'insécurité quand les
français se plaignent en leur disais
mais c'est un sentiment d'insécurité
et puis on trafique a les statistiques
pour avoir une stabilité aujourd'hui et
statistiques pourquoi pour le point
d'insécurité pour faire croire que
c'était stable aujourd'hui non là pour
le coup voilà parle michel l'intérieur à
l'époque voilà bon aujourd'hui plus
personne aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
plus personne ne conteste que
l'insécurité augmente et est un problème
là on a le même problème pour pouvoir
d'achat les trois quarts des français
pensent qu'ils baissent et l'insee nous
affirme qu'il augmente donc il ya un
moment il faut il faut mettre les choses
au clair sur la façon de calculer le
pouvoir d'achat il pouvoir d'achat c'est
très simple c'est l'augmentation des
salaires
- l'augmentation des prix mais on
comprend dans cette équation que si les
prix l'oma si l'augmentation des prix
est sous-estimé ça va permettre de
dégager un pouvoir d'achat mais qui sera
plus factice qui ne sera par ailleurs le
mental qui s'ajoute à ça mais évidemment
on va en parler justement de ce décalage
puisque nous avons benoît ourliac inde
de l'insee comment est ce que l'insee
calcule ce fameux pouvoir d'achat qui
fait débat en tout cas alors d'abord
peut-être
j'ai envie de revenir sur ce sentiment
de décalage que qui a été exprimée ici
encore sur ce plateau entre le ressenti
des français et puis les statistiques de
l'insee publie sur le pouvoir d'achat
ce que j'aimerais vraiment dire c'est
expliqué c'est que que raconte
exactement ces statistiques ce qu'elles
décrivent c'est quand même une situation
qui est inédite aujourd'hui en france
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
ce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est
que le pouvoir d'achat des ménages dans
les statistiques de l'insee a stagné
depuis pendant près de dix ans c'est à
dire sur la période allant de 2007 à
il a il a stagné si on regarde plus dans
le détail on peut décomposer en deux
phases on a eu une première phase après
la crise financière ou le pouvoir
d'achat a diminué
ça aussi c'est dans nos statistiques
n'importe qui peut le constater c'est ce
que l'on raconte
il a reculé de 2007 à 2013 grosso modo
enfin exactement et ensuite il s'est
redressé depuis 2013 il a commencé à
réaugmenter très timidement où on est
sur des progressions dans le comprise
entre 0 % et 1 % par an donc on est
quand même sur des choses qui sont aussi
très faible on a on ne raconte pas que
le pouvoir d'achat est en train de l'est
en train d'exploser et de fait de ce
rythme modéré ce n'est que en 2018 qu'il
a retrouvé son niveau de 2007 donc son
niveau de onze ans auparavant donc on a
vraiment une période de stagnation
pendant pendant 11 ans et ce qu'il faut
rappeler aussi c'est que cette
statistique dont tout le monde parle
c'est une moyenne
c'est une moyenne dans la tranche par
tranche évidemment quand on regarde
quand cherchant ses différents et quand
on a un pouvoir d'achat qui fait du
surplace en moyenne pour l'ensemble de
la population
comme toute moyenne il ya des gens qui
sont au dessus il ya des gens qui sont
en dessous donc un pouvoir d'achat qui a
stagné pendant plus de dix ans en
moyenne
ça veut dire que pour une fraction très
significative de la population
ce pouvoir d'achat a baissé
[Musique]